[Music]  aquariums have been around for hundreds  of years even now having a body of water  in a glass box seems like magic  the most common aquarium fish is the  goldfish domesticated in China more than  a thousand years ago goldfish are a type  of carp native to Asia they tend to be  silver or gray in color but ancient  Chinese breeders took advantage of  orange and yellow mutations to breed  gold colored fish like all fish goldfish  start life as eggs to start the breeding  process  a worker separates the males from the  females  telling the girls from the boys can be  difficult but if she finds eggs there's  no question it must be female the eggs  fall to the bottom  this facility harvests around a thousand  eggs a day adding oxygen helps the eggs  mature a week later the eggs hatch the  hatchings are called fry by the second  week their little fish not all of them  are the typical orange color even after  centuries of breeding many of them are  still silver and gray